[Music]
this article i think is really funny
because of the lack of information so
maybe we could use our creativity and
fill it with blanks
my favorite so this is over in the uk
um
basically a man was arrested for
stealing another man's phone uh-huh
during a hug he gave him in the bathroom
what that's some ocean's 11 [ __ ]
back pocket why are they hugging in the
bathroom right that's like the last
place that i'm hugging anybody don't
talk to him i'm in a peace dog
like your eyes are like dead ahead like
does not deviate from this line
but you can't picture two drunk blokes
like
like connecting over like pissing
[Laughter]
i just can't i know that that's a way of
like pickpocketing but i can't
understand how you can like can you go
like so from the back anymore
he makes someone think that's a natural
thing well the pickpocket probably he
did it because it was unexpected that's
probably his angle the bathroom oh yeah
you know so it's actually a pretty slick
move
you guys ever been pickpocketed i have
not i've been i've had like someone take
something my wallet out of my bag as i
was holding it
i was in line at fisherman's wharf in
san francisco yeah and i was just like
no it was actually it was actually in
seattle so you're watching people throw
the salmon and [ __ ] oh wow you're crap i
just remember i remember distinctly that
i had stood in line at three different
places and i should have known i was i
was like a teenager but the same dude
was behind me at the last two places oh
wow and he didn't buy anything
so i was like the [ __ ] is this guy
always here so i was then i was buying
food and i was holding my bag like this
i wasn't looking as i was ordering and
then right after that i was like what
happened to the other guy and i looked
and he was gone and didn't get anything
after me the third time
and i was like oh [ __ ] my wallet's gone
he just reached in and took it
yeah and that was it i had a friend that
was like backpacking through europe
and then he was like at a cafe and he
had his backpack between his legs while
i was eating and when he was done eating
was gone what the [ __ ] yeah dude i hear
that like certain parts of france and
[ __ ] like that are like the olympics of
pickpocketing
or brazil too yeah like they have teams
like the mom with the baby like they
know how to distract you with like three
or four one sec just that quick yeah
that quick they watch and like
especially to see you by yourself
he's a victim he's not a group because
it's like you're you're you're unaware
yeah all right guys he's american
get him yeah i was watching 11 stuff i
was watching this video of this dude in
africa that was like baiting like people
that'll try and jack his phone he had
his phone like hanging out of the uh out
of a car that was like moving like
through the streets or whatever and then
with a camera like this and you see the
guy like and he's like breaking down
like so then this guy gives a signal to
other guy to like come later so that guy
peels off and eventually like intercepts
it here and then jacks it and so you
would see though because he's expecting
it or whatever you can see that that
tells whatever he like yanks it back
he's like he pokes that out he's like
what are you doing
damn that's crazy yeah it's
choreographed man i mean it's and some
people that's their whole thing of the
catch marks they sit at the train
station all day
at the bus station you're thinking i do
do you know
it's fun oh you've never been here like
okay pictures yeah
he's one you know you got a lot of
people they're not like you know even
like when you go to venice those guys
put a gd man hey and the people okay
you know they're intimidating like
bullying you like hip-hop
listen to hip-hop
there's nothing on this cd
every time i go to europe i always get
one of those uh you know those like
those flesh colored uh
inside fanny packs so that my pockets
are empty and i have to like lift up my
shirt to like open it i always have a
dummy wallet whoa yeah what's in it
nothing
like this
you know what i used to do back in the
day like when i said sell dope i just
keep all my money in my shoes so
remember go old school
keep your id and [ __ ] so i'd be like in
the street and you pick it all dudes
like run up on you dude i got nothing
and you got like a thousand dollars
you know i mean
up out of there whatever you make so
much money that your shoes becomes huge
are you like standing crooked yeah you
have to shoot so you'd be kind of
walking but when you got too big you got
to go get rid of something because so
you try to have like you know if you got
pants you got socks but you always keep
it down to where somebody's got to
actually get down you don't want to ever
have you know you know [ __ ]
becoming pocket check man you know
somebody like are you like oh i ain't
got nothing to do to try and see how
much money you made so you're like all
right i got like 40 bucks and you got
all your [ __ ] in your shoes so would you
put it inside your sock or yeah i think
it inside but i used to also like lay it
flat and it's like
layered it on the bottom of my shoe when
i was a kid like a little insult like a
little insole by time i get home i pull
that thing out and it's all sweaty and
[ __ ]
worth it though i was protected
like blow drying that's how we just
hired our money back in the day man yeah
man yeah you can try to figure out
what's the most money you've walked
around with in your shoe i don't know i
was a kid man so it might have been like
you know maybe like i don't know eight
hundred bucks sometimes
yeah kid money that kid money you know
just from hustling because like you know
i saw a house at the park you said you
were 15 at this time i was 15 i was
selling dope down the street a lot of
[ __ ] money for a 15 year old but you
know really we were getting they were
getting over on us because i didn't
understand
like mathematics and breaking [ __ ] down
instead of instead of buying
like say
a quarter pound i would get like a 1200
double up and they were called charging
me retail because i didn't know the game
so they're really getting over on but
you think you're making money but have
you bought the qp and broke it down
rocket so you made triple you know and
that's not because i was trying to do
[ __ ] we were just you know trying to be
entrepreneurs but that's just the first
job
everybody has the first stop my first
job was giant rockets yeah
they're [ __ ] be over there too you
know different ways completely different
they got over in him too yeah
what's this article about dude
you got pickpocketed in the bathroom
in the bathroom yeah
dude sometimes people try and talk to me
in bathrooms like in bars and stuff like
that and just like you get talked to in
the bathroom sometimes like some drunk
dudes just like oh can you believe this
[ __ ] outside i'm like
not now like dude like i'm not i'm not
having this you gotta be careful too
because people try you like you said
dude
another story like my buddy in the
bathroom
he was peeing and reno and a dude died
or act like he knew me kicked him and
kicked him in the butt and he peed on
himself like he had versace on like it's
nice and he's like what the [ __ ] and
dude's like oh man i'm sorry mother
thought you was like see [ __ ]
man i do like [ __ ] you and my homeboy
took off on a big big bing was [ __ ]
him up security comes in seeing him
beating his ass but dude kicked him and
asked he peed on him so so he caught a
case in the bathroom oh no he had to pay
that guy like 10 grand
that dude's goal is to like just get the
[ __ ] kicked out of him so he could get
like a case no he he was talking [ __ ]
but he didn't know that my buddy my
homeboy like he's a like a gangster type
dude you know i mean he's like dude you
know he's like you know if you do it
instead of part me like what the [ __ ]
he's like oh man dude damn dude i was up
in here oh man my bad is like yeah man
watch yourself yeah man he said [ __ ] you
what was it what you did at martin
but all i see with him on the ground and
my boy whooping his ass and he actually
told the judge and dude like oh man i
didn't do nothing like dude you
[ __ ] kicked me my ass
made me peel myself that's when i was 19
though yeah now it's just i'm so sorry
you know oh yeah so if someone was
trying to like push you to find out uh
whatever i'm so sorry i don't know i
don't mean to do anything just like when
when i was 19 still had like the high
school mindset in that environment
that's just what it is now it says oh
i'm so sorry what about like tyson
remember tyson that guy in the airplane
yeah
he had to come in
like he deserved it was always like like
like who is this dude man i bet the
stewardess were like yo let this fool
get yeah
they were like oh this guy sucks and the
and they build up on like yo ty like
basically said oh he had to come and he
was like he had prior history
[Laughter]
make up a new rap sheet for him yeah
so same situation if you were tyson some
guy's doing that [ __ ] to you bart from
jk what's up you would probably ask to
move seats or something
yeah
dude so you got it you got to think but
at some time at some point you also got
to like because i was in the situ and i
was in a grocery i mean um in the gas
station and this dude came in there
and i'm like like he said i'm like this
is kind of weird he's looking oh
300 you're a big guy huh blah blah blah
yeah and this indian dude he's in there
looking like oh [ __ ] you know and then
i'm looking and doing
i can take you and he starts doing like
this little stance i'm like dude
you know back to [ __ ] you get on my
space man yeah you know i'm not gonna
let you get caught you might have a
knife or anything and he's like oh you
know what you're gonna do i'm like dude
you're getting close i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up bro and i was gonna do this chop him
in the neck hella hard
where do you aim where do you aim for
this right here just make him choke up
real quick just he wouldn't even see
that coming and then his buddy comes in
and says hey man hey hey calm down we're
not supposed to be doing that there's
some homeless at their working area so
he came in there and calmed his buddy
down and then the indian dude was
looking but it was all on camera but
like dude you if you would that's
violated my space i'm not i'm i'm not
even trying to but just do this pressing
the phones what do you do you can't be
too light you bet you gotta watch them
i might just [ __ ] run out the other
way i was like because i didn't want to
turn my back because he's moving like
you know because i'm like this and i'm
like watching i'm trying to pay but i'm
at the same time i don't want to you
know so i'm like standing back and then
this guy came and de-escalated the
situation but there's certain people
like i'm just always conscious because
you never know who's a weirdo these days
for like legal purposes if you've in
that situation and you were to hit him
would you get in trouble for that well
if he threw the first yeah you threw the
first punch i would have to try to
unless a guy indian guy said he provoked
or he did something like he looked like
he was threatening like he made a
threatening movement he corroborates you
know i mean yeah he's like oh that guy
came in here he threatened that he was
gonna do something and then for my i
feared for my safety yeah somebody said
you fear for my life yeah like dude i
didn't know he you know that guy had a
knife i might i might throw a little
knife down there he had a knife yeah
look look look it says big herc on it
but it's his he brought it out
because you know at some point you can't
be you can't let yourself to be a victim
and that's what people expect oh well
you should have did dude this month if i
would have acted first i'd be alive yeah
i wouldn't cut the you know whatever i
caught especially when it's all verbal
leading up to that point oh man this is
weirdos and and then you know people
they think they can get away with
anything nowadays and then some people
try to do you know they'll try to do
something go viral you know what about
them walking up just hitting people in
and filming it yeah i don't know if you
remember this one car this one car show
we me and you were at we were at one of
those car meets and then um i parked my
car i had my 79 camaro at the time
and then uh i came back to it later to
get something out of the car and then um
this guy i guess was taking a picture of
it at the moment that i like had just
walked up and he was like hey thanks
[ __ ] get in the way my [ __ ] photo
oh my god
what a [ __ ] i was like this is
actually my car i'm just i'm just
getting something from it and like i
think everyone was already looking so he
didn't want to like i thought he thought
he got to be dumb if he backed off of
what he said and he goes
yeah well i was still trying to take a
photo of it [ __ ] [ __ ] like he was
mad at me
and then like i was just looking around
everybody i'm like
what happens now
and then barrett was there too like all
of her homies were around and everyone
was just so stunned because it was like
a stalemate they were like wow this
guy's clearly embarrassed but he's like
but buffing up even more yeah trying to
act like he's not yeah
so we were just like
okay uh go ahead take your picture then
and i just stood there
[Music]
you